wir schauen auf dieses mega feier in
berlin ein munitionslager der polizei in
flammen hier in der hauptstadt mitten im
krone walter knallt es seit den frühen
morgenstunden
ja das ist eine dramatische lage
mittlerweile das feuer gilt in diesen
stunden als unlösbar das ist heute früh
gegen halb vier also eine ganz frühen
morgenstunden dort ausgebrochen das ist
ein riesiges gelände im südwesten von
berlins und da hat die polizei seit
jahrzehnten munition gelagert aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg über 50 tonnen davon
und illegales feuerwerk und das erklärt
auch warum das im moment als unlösbar
gilt das ist weiträumig umzäunen
patricia und man kommt eben bis jetzt
hier sehen wir diesen zaun nicht dran an
diese flammen einfach zu gefährlich ja
es gab einen lauten knall heute nacht es
sind viele aus ihren betten nach oben
gefahren es war 3 uhr 30 am morgen nicht
mehr als 1000 meter kommen die
feuerwehrleute derzeit ran heute ein
ganz heißer tag hier in der hauptstadt
über 30 grad das ist staubtrocken in den
wäldern da draußen in der natur der
grunewald am stadtrand aber doch auch
wohngebiet drumherum und derzeit so sagt
uns die feuerwehr ist das feuer nicht
kontrollierbar jetzt rückt auch die
bundeswehr an um dort unter die arme zu
greifen dort zu helfen denn dann
fürchtet natürlich weitere extras und
was für bilder hier also das war um etwa
33 4 uhr heute früh und alle die die
südlich vom zentrum berlins wohnen die
haben das auch gehört sie sehen warum
weil da richtig was in die luft geflogen
ist hier saß teilweise sogar ganz schön
aus dann am morgendlichen himmel über
berlin weil eben da auch illegales
feuerwerk gelagert ist aber es gab
heftige detonationen explosion patrizia
hat das selbst erlebt heute früh sodass
wirklich ja die wände gewackelt haben
dort im südwesten von berlin unser bild
reporter benjamin trump ist sofort in
aller frühe heute dort hingefahren und
ja beobachtet derzeit stunden da diese
muss man sagen mittlerweile
verzweifelten löscharbeiten denn die
ganzen und polizeieinsatzkräfte
feuerwehreinsatzkräfte die kommen ja
nach wie vor nicht ran an den brandherd
und genau das ist das problem der
sprengplatz der polizei sprengt sich
seit heute morgen quasi selbst die lage
ist nach wie vor unübersichtlich um ein
bisschen mehr deutlichkeit in dieses
unterfangen zu bringen befinden wir uns
jetzt hier quasi im lagezentrum von
feuerwehr von polizei von allen weiteren
kräften und bei mir der pressedienst der
berliner feuerwehr james klein was
passiert hier genau ja genau das ist das
lagezentrum kann man sagen mobile
lagezentrum der berliner feuerwehr
hier ist die gemeinsame einsatzleitung
die man bei so einer großen lage braucht
in diesen großen fahrzeug was man mit
hintergrund zieht treffen sich alle
behörden organisationen institutionen
die hier schnittstellen übergreifen
zusammenarbeiten denn anders geht es in
so einer lage nicht hier kann man sich
gemeinsam die lage anschauen die drohnen
bilder kommen hier rein und auch für den
satelliten vom hubschrauber man trifft
sich regelmäßig um die lage abzustimmen
und dann gezielt die maßnahmen
abzustimmen und aufträge zu verteilen
wir haben lösch panzer der polizei
gesehen es sind löschboote in der
liebburg
zugange die die waldwege befeuchten
gerade die dafür sorgen die den wald
bewässern dass jetzt der weit nicht noch
mehr schaden nimmt 20.000 quadratmeter
sind ist zur stunde wie ist die lage
aktuell ja die lage ist immer noch
unübersichtlich kann man sich vorstellen
warum wir können einfach immer noch
nicht in diesem radius von den 1000
metern die hier auch einfach der
sprengmeister weiterhin vor gibt auch
noch bis zum mindestens mittags
verlängert hat die feuerwehr kann nicht
reinfahren die gefahr für mensch und
material ist hier einfach zu hoch wir
müssen abwarten das spezialgerät der
polizei und auch der bundeswehr
unbemannte roboter lösch panzer wie
schon erwähnt hier einfach uns
unterstützen und auch weiter in diesen
raum eindringen können aber was können
wir machen wir haben rund um diese 1000
meter die brandbekämpfung sichergestellt
wir haben die wasserversorgung
sichergestellt um so die ausbreitung
außerhalb dieses radius ist einfach hier
zu verhindern also zwei große
herausforderungen die gefahr des
springplatzes und die enorme ausbreitung
bei diesen temperaturen momentan sind
auch löschhubschrauber angefragt die zum
einsatz kommen sollen aber die haben
auch ein problem gerade das stichwort
sicherheitsradius welches problem
tauchte auf bevölkerung stellt sich
häufig vor der radius erstreckt sich
dann nur von links nach rechts aber das
ganze geht natürlich auch in die höhe
und wenn man sich das vorstellen einen
kilometer in die höhe auch ein speer
radius und da oben wird ein kleines
paket wasser dann noch einfach geöffnet
da kommt auch nicht mehr viel an also
ein problem der stadt jospeh radius geht
auch in den luftraum das zweite problem
auch aufgrund der aktuellen lage auch
bundesweit die löschhubschrauber sind
natürlich auch woanders im einsatz vor
allem sächsische schweiz deutschland
gerade betroffen aufgrund der dürre die
wir momentan zu beklagen haben es sind
lösch hubschrauber im einsatz ist sind
drohnen im einsatz wie gefährlich sie
haben auch angesprochen die bundeswehr
ist jetzt angefragt worden die sollte
innerhalb der nächsten stunden jetzt
hoffentlich hier eintreffen welche
gefahren lauern nämlich bei der
bewältigung dieses brandes jetzt hier
aktuell im grunewald nämlich für die
einsatzkräfte bei normalen waldbrand hat
man einfach nur den rauch und auch die
die flammen hier haben wir einfach die
kampfmittel und hier haben wir die
detonation die explosion das ist die
besondere herausforderung für die
berliner feuerwehr
darum haben wir uns auch einfach dieses
spezialwissen geholt die bundeswehr und
den sprengmeister das hier ganz einfach
mit dem wissen dieser kräfte und auch
mit dem material was jetzt gegen mittag
eintreffen soll auch boden gebunden
vorzugehen und ein besseres lagebild zu
bekommen und auch den löschangriff
anzugehen ein kollege sagte vorhin solch
eine lage solch eine situation erlebt
ein feuerwehr tatsächlich vielleicht nur
einmal im leben warum das ist ja heute
so katastrophal gelaufen da ist
natürlich monierte lage wenn man jetzt
alles zusammenfasst die herausforderung
die wege die wege das land schwärzungen
zum feuer einfach hin kommt die gefahr
die entsteht durch die detonation und
die explosion dem sperr radius das
natürlich die 37 grad die vegetation die
hier einfach maximal trocken ist und
natürlich auch die körperliche belastung
für die einsatzkräfte wenn man das in
summe nimmt wenn man da zurück denkt ist
das schon eine einmalige herausforderung
in den letzten jahrzehnten für die
berliner feuerwehr was wird hier alles
gelagert wir haben gehört 50 tonnen
weltkriegsmunition was es darüber hinaus
noch hier zu finden was wird hier
normalerweise gelagert eine rücksprache
mit dem sprengmeister werden die
verschiedene sprengmittel gelagert da
fängt es an von feuerwerkskörpern aber
wie sie auch schon sagen kampfmittel bis
zu 50 tonnen die natürlich
unterschiedlich auch unter einem
unterschiedlichen schutz gelagert werden
aber es ist schon eine große summe an
kampfmitteln und sprengstoffen dort
vorhanden sodass der der ein kilometer
radius auch unbedingt eingehalten werden
muss ganz kurz noch weil sie sagen
sicherheitsradius sicherheit geht vor
wie groß ist jetzt die gefahr
abschließend für menschen in der näheren
umgebung anwohner gebäude die gefahr für
die menschen nur die bevölkerung ist
erst mal sagen wir mal relativ gering
wir haben das glück dass es im grunewald
stattfinde darum ist der sprengplatz
auch dort gelegen auch wenn man den 1000
kilometer radius nimmt könnte man auch
noch mal 1000 meter drauf setzen auch
dann wäre es nur in anführungsstrichen
waldgebiet so dass die bevölkerung hier
erstmal sagen wir mal keiner gefahr
ausgesetzt ist darum haben wir auch die
s-bahn und auch die autobahn weiterhin
bis mittags erstmal gesperrt und wir
waren pro aktiv und transparent über
unsere waren es schon von morgen an und
den ganzen tag wichtiges signal in
diesen minuten an die bevölkerung die
ursachenforschung wird die polizei
übernehmen das zur stunde aber erst
einmal hinten an gestellt jetzt geht es
erst einmal um die brandbekämpfung hier
im berliner grunewald vielen vielen dank
eines clans gegeben erst einmal wieder
zu
dieser munition lagerplatz dort weil der
presse kollege davon der feuerwehr
gerade gesagt hat unterschiedlich
gelagert also sind da noch mal
lagerhallen war lag das sind bunkern
drin weil es erstaunlich ein bisschen
dass das alles halt hoch gehen konnte
heute in der früh hat man da listen was
genau gelagert ist weiß man auch was da
schon in die luft gegangen ist was
explodiert ist vielleicht weiß die
feuerwehr da ein bisschen was
eine frage noch ganz kurz die haben
gesagt dass die munition teilweise in
bunkern untergebracht wurde teilweise
aber auch offen liegen wissen sie können
sie uns zur stunde sagen was genau da
gelagert wird und wie die lagerung
zustände da jeweils sind gibt es
ranglisten
die man nachvollziehen kann natürlich
dem stylisten da gibt es auch
vorschriften aktuell kann da nur der
sprengmeister die genaue details
erklären aber stellen sie sich vor da da
sind natürlich unterschiedliche klassen
ausgelagert wird vielleicht mit einem
normalen behälter in normalen häusern
das dann auch durch eine brandmauer
schlagen brand leichter deponiert oder
explodiert aber die wirklich großen
kampfmittel oder die eine große
explosion die man halt morgen gehört hat
die werden natürlich unter bestimmten
und großen sicherheitsauflagen und
gekühlt und in stahlbehältern gelagert
so dass man da erst mal nicht die ängste
hat dass da was passiert hoffen wir das
beste
soviel dazu also verschiedene
lagerungsmöglichkeiten dafür und auch
verschiedene klassen von
feuerwerkskörper bis zur kriegsmunition
umso wichtiger dass so schnell wie
möglich die bundeswehr denn hier anrückt
um dementsprechend hilfe zu leisten viel
vielen dank herr klein wir gehen zurück
bis nachher ja danke benjamin also wir
sehen auch schon die ersten
bundeswehrsoldaten dahinter dir also das
gerät der bundeswehr wird am mittag dann
dort erwartet das haben wir gerade
gehört wie können noch mal live bilder
sehen von oben drauf auf dieses mega
feier im südwesten von berlin so sieht
es im moment aus die rauchschwaden die
auch hier bei uns ein mittel in berlin
mitte im zentrum zu sehen sind dort
hinten in den wäldern im südwesten weil
das ist ein mega mega brand das ist
nicht so weit vom stadtzentrum vor allem
von q dorf 20 belegt mit dem autor das
ist ein ganz ganz beliebtes
naherholungsgebiet dort geht mit meinem
hund spazieren
dort geht man meinen kaffee trinken dort
läuft normal durch den wald derzeit ist
der brand mindestens so groß wie zwei
fußballfelder und wie wir gerade gehört
haben das ist schwer zu kontrollieren
ist schwer zu sagen was da noch alles in
die luft gehen könnte und die feuerwehr
kommt nicht ran der sprengmeister
verboten da näher als 1000 meter ran zu
kommen ja das ist schon interessant die
feuerwehr dir gar nicht löscht im moment
die versuchen nur den brand einzudämmen
also die
teilen das wasser drumherum aus rund um
diesen korridor von über einem kilometer
wo man im moment sagt das ist einfach zu
gefährlich da weiter anzugehen man sieht
ja auch wie ja wie weitflächig
mittlerweile dieser brand ist und auf
diesem gelände eben alle spaziergänger
im südwesten berlins die kennen dieses
gelände das ist weiträumig abgesperrt
normalerweise hört man da auch die eine
oder andere explosion dass es durchaus
normal da im grunewald wenn eben
kontrolliert gesprengt wird und heute
früh klang das du hast das erlebten ganz
anders da weiß halt 330 da wackelten die
wände dass das aktuelle bild der blick
über diesen grünewald südwestlich vom
zentrum berlins wenn jemand rampf unser
kollege ist seit der frühen morgen dort
vor ort und mit ihm wollen wir jetzt
auch direkt sprechen denn es gibt
neueste informationen dort und es läuft
auch eine pressekonferenz der berliner
polizei bereits hier im grunewald sind
mit den zuständigen wochen eingetroffen
und haben dann dort festgestellt dass es
sich um den entsprechenden sprengplatz
der polizei hier in grunewald handelt
wir sind in hervorragend zur
zusammenarbeit mit den verantwortlichen
die diesen sprengplatz besetzen und
erste maßnahmen eingeleitet haben dann
in die brandbekämpfung eingestiegen im
rahmen der brandbekämpfung ist
pyrotechnik umgesetzt worden das heißt
sie wurde entzündet und unsere
kolleginnen und kollegen die angehören
der berliner feuerwehr sahen sich
plötzlich konfrontiert mit
umherfliegenden trümmerteilen und haben
hier unter einsatz ihres lebens dann
auch den rückzug angetreten auch das
eine wichtige und richtige entscheidung
unseres einsatzleiters zumal wir zu dem
zeitpunkt ausschließen konnten dass
menschen in gefahr sich befinden in
absprache mit den verantwortlichen haben
wir dann einen sperrkreis festgelegt im
radius von 1000 metern um dieses gelände
und haben dort uns dann zurückgezogen um
gemeinsam mit allen beteiligten hier im
rahmen der erkundung auch zunächst
einmal festzustellen von welchen
bereichen mit welchen weiteren
umsetzungen auch ausgegangen werden kann
erkundungen die wir vorgenommen haben
mit unseren brunnen die wir gemeinsam
vorgenommen haben auch aus der luft über
den polizeihubschrauber erkundungen die
wir aber jetzt auch weiter fortsetzen
boden gebunden ohne menschen in den
bereich hinein zu bringen sie wissen
worauf ich an spiele nämlich auf
entsprechende ferngesteuerte fahrzeuge
die jetzt im zulauf sind wo wir uns ein
bild machen können an welcher stelle es
entsprechend hier noch einen
gefahrenschwerpunkt gibt den es zu
bekämpfen gilt wir haben frühzeitig uns
heute morgen mit allen beteiligten
behörden leitungen auch zusammen
telefoniert und sind auch frühzeitig
hier im schulterschluss an dieser
einsatzstelle unterwegs und sie sehen
hinter mir nicht nur auch die in
senatorin und die polizeipräsidentin
sondern auch general uchtmann als die in
kommandeur des landeskommandos wir
stehen seit vielen stunden heute in
kontakt und auch hier hat die bundeswehr
aktiv hilfe angeboten auf die ich gerne
auch eingegangen bin sie sehen es ist
hier
multiprofessionelle interdisziplinär in
dieser ganz besondere lage weil es auch
für uns als feuerwehr kein alltag ist
dass wir zu brandt ereignissen gerufen
werden die ursächlich durch umsetzende
munition entsprechend entstanden sind
wir haben eine führungsstruktur
aufgebaut die sehen sie dort hinter mir
wir sind mit führungs einheiten vor ort
wir sind im augenblick 120 einsatzkräfte
der berliner feuerwehr und eine vielzahl
von einsatzkräften aus den
unterschiedlichsten bereichen über den
rettungsdienst bis hin zu den betreuungs
einheiten der hilfsorganisationen aber
auch die entsprechenden betreiber von
stromnetzen berlin forst und auch
ähnliche um die exemplarisch einige zu
nennen die alle hier an dieser stelle
all ihren beitrag im rahmen der
erkundung und informationen uns liefern
können es geht jetzt im nächsten schritt
nach den erkundungen die wir mit
ferngesteuerten einsatzmitteln vornehmen
wollen und auch weiter über die
luftaufklärung unterstützen wollen jetzt
den einsatzschwerpunkt entsprechend zu
setzen um dann auch neu zu bewerten wie
dieser sicherheitsradius entsprechend zu
sehen ist ein sicherheitsradius der
jetzt noch auswirkungen hat auf die
verkehrsinfrastruktur sie selbst haben
es wahrscheinlich entsprechend erlebt
dass die autobahn gesperrt ist dass die
zugverbindung gesperrt ist all das sind
auswirkungen aus diesem
sicherheitsradius von 1000 metern im
umfeld sie sehen jetzt gleich ein
treffen auch ein wasserwerfer der
polizei sie sehen wir sind da sehr
interdisziplinär unterwegs die auf grund
ihrer panzerung die dieses fahrzeug ist
auch hat sprechen dem umfeld also
außerhalb des 1000 meter radius
bereiches auch die welt die zugangswege
auch wässert und für uns sicherstellen
möchte mit dem rahmen der möglichkeiten
das auch durch umgesetzte munition die
umherfliegen ist ja der
sicherheitsradius
gerechtfertigt an dieser stelle auch
wege schon gewässert werden und eine
brandentstehung vermieden wird eine
brandentstehung die nicht ganz
auszuschließen ist wir haben auch dort
erkundungs ergebnisse die uns jetzt in
der vorbereitung als berliner feuerwehr
schon vor stunden dahingehend
beschäftigt hat das hier im rahmen der
wasserversorgung die hier vom
öffentlichen hydrantennetz natürlich
anders ist in diesem ländlichen bereich
als wenn wir städtische unterwegs wären
wir haben aber dafür in unmittelbarer
nähe offene gewässer so dass wir aus der
krummen lanke heraus und aus der lieper
bucht der havel auch schon eine
unabhängige wasserversorgung aufbauen
konnten und auch jetzt vorbereitet sind
dann in die unmittelbare brandbekämpfung
einzustellen es gilt also jetzt hier
gemeinsam die erkundungs ergebnisse zu
verifizieren eventuell andere oder
veränderte punkte und einsatz punkte
festzulegen um dann in einer abstimmung
konzertiert entsprechend auch tätig
werden zu können das ist die aktuelle
lage die uns und das glaube ich können
sie erkennen noch einige zeit hier
beschäftigen wird und insofern danke ich
ihnen für ihr zu hören
umsätzen von munition ist der
fachbegriff wenn munition halt ausgelöst
wird wenn sie explodiert wenn sie
bestimmungsgemäß das macht was sie dass
sie da ist was aber für uns natürlich
mit umherfliegenden trümmerteilen mit
einer druck entsprechenden wolken sprint
verbunden ist und ähnlichen
nein einfach durch welche maßnahmen auch
immer thermische aufbereitung echt aber
da dürfen sie gerne auch dann sicherlich
in zugleich gesprächen die
verantwortlichen und die kompetenten
stellen fragen ja danke frau schwanger
also dass die ersten informationen jetzt
von der liste der berner feuerwerk hast
mich 1000 der chef der berliner
feuerwehr und jetzt in berliner polizei
chefin barbara slowik
gewesen gemeinsam mit der feuerwehr
gemeinsam mit der bundeswehr gemeinsam
natürlich mit der berliner polizei das
heißt also ich bin jetzt hierher
gefahren um mir dann auch die situation
vor ort genau anzuschauen
für mich war es sehr sehr wichtig gleich
auch mit polizei feuerwehr und
bundeswehr sicherzustellen dass die
berlinerinnen und berliner die hier im
umfeld ja auch wohnen dass da eine
sicherheit vorhanden ist das heißt also
wir haben sehr genau abgesprochen wie
weit der radius natürlich sein muss und
und und das heißt also wir haben hier
keinerlei toxische gegenstände weil auch
das ist ja sehr wichtig geht hier
eventuell auch eine explosion herbei
gegenständen das ist nicht der fall also
insofern kann ich sie jetzt auch erstmal
beruhigen die technischen sachen hat
herr homrighausen alle gesagt ich
bedanke mich sehr herzlich sowohl bei
den einsatzkräften die also hier sehr
schnell auch vor ort waren als auch
natürlich bei der polizei und bei der
bundeswehr weil es ist sehr sehr wichtig
dass wir hier hand in hand arbeiten
wir haben natürlich auch uns angeschaut
und deshalb habe ich mir jetzt auch die
lage natürlich auch mit fragen
hinterfragt
dass wir hier natürlich auch in der wahl
gegen bestimmte sachen gemacht haben die
auch schon im vorfeld wichtig waren also
dass man im gestrüpp und so weiter was
natürlich auch schnell brennbar ist das
hat man alles schon auch im herbst
letzten jahres hier mit entsprechenden
gängen durch den wald alles abgesichert
dass das nicht mehr wahr wir werden
jetzt natürlich nachdem wir die lage
ja nicht nur beurteilt haben sondern
dann natürlich auch entsprechend sicher
gestellt haben werden wir
selbstverständlich dann auch die
ursachenforschung machen ich habe stehe
natürlich mit der regierenden
bürgermeisterin in ständigem kontakt sie
ist auch sie unterbricht ihren urlaub
und wird hier auch herkommen und wird
sich auch selbst noch mal ein bild der
lage machen ich habe natürlich auch die
fraktionen im abgeordnetenhaus
informiert damit war es ja doch ein
bisschen aufregung jetzt natürlich
bekannterweise auch gegeben hat aber wir
können jetzt noch nichts weiteres sagen
was für mich wichtig ist dass die
sicherheit der berlinerinnen und
berliner nicht gefährdet ist und dass es
hier gegeben und danke ich sehr sehr bei
den einsatzkräften die jetzt hier vor
ort sind dass sie das wirklich so auch
im griff dankeschön wir sprechen gleich
mit unseren kollegen benjamin trump der
ist die ganze zeit dort vor ort und der
bringt uns auf dem laufenden im moment
breitet sich das feuer breiten sich die
flammen dort weiter aus die polizei und
die feuerwehr durch sprechen im moment
von einem unkoordinierten feuer also das
ist einfach etwas sperrige begriff dafür
aber bedeutet eben da ist nichts unter
kontrolle und die fahren immer mehr
gerät auf mittlerweile schwere
räumpanzer dort wasserwerfer aufgefahren
wir hören sogar dass die bundeswehr um
hilfe gebeten wurde weil das eben ein
munitions gebieten hoch gefährliches
gebiet dort ist unser reporter ist jetzt
dort hinter dem zaun benjamin traf unser
bild reporter der das seit den frühen
morgenstunden dort verfolgt das hat mir
ehrlich gesagt habe ein bisschen angst
gemacht dass die feuerwehr nach so
vielen stunden sagt das ist
unkoordinierten kommen da gar nicht ran
wir können uns das aus der luft
irgendwie angucken ist das ein eindruck
dort von den einsatzkräften bei denen du
dich da gerade befindest benjamin
es ist tatsächlich der fall dass die
feuerwehr keine chance hat sich etwas
dichter noch an diesen brandherd heran
zu tasten es ist ein umkreis von 1000
metern geschaffen worden es ist zu
gefährlich und deshalb ihr habt es auch
gerade eben angesprochen ist auch die
bundeswehr angefordert worden weil die
kennt sich aus mit unwegsamen gelände
die kommt jetzt hier mit stark
gepanzerten fahrzeug an die rollen hier
vor gleich in wenigen minuten soll es
dann soweit sein die können dann wie im
kriegsfall sich dann tatsächlich immer
dichter an diesen brandherd rantasten
und sind dann zum einen fahrzeug
technisch geschützt und natürlich auch
das personal selbst geschützt weil die
normalen feuerwehrautos die polizei die
wasserwerfer die würden derartige
explosionen detonationen nicht
wegstecken können
denn beschreibt uns einmal den grunewald
für all die die nicht aus der hauptstadt
gekommen die den grünewald nicht kennen
wie bedrohlich ist die situation gibt es
da wohnen gegen denn in der nähe derzeit
breitet sich das feuer jahr weiterhin
unkontrolliert aus kann das gefährlich
werden irgendwann für anwohner
momentan brennen hier wohl 15.000
quadratmeter 1,5 hektar das sind
umgerechnet circa zwei fußballfelder die
hier seit den frühen morgenstunden
brennen hier werden 50 tonnen
weltkriegsbomben gelagert darunter auch
noch illegales feuerwerk was dann hier
zu gegebener stunde kontrolliert
gesprengt wird das werden die berliner
das werden die brandenburger kennen wenn
die avus hier im bereich hüttenweg dann
immer mal wieder in den sommermonaten
für ein paar minuten gesperrt wird damit
es hier zu diesen kontrollierten
sprengungen kommen kann glücklicherweise
befindet sich dieses munitionslager der
polizei im grunewald selbst also es sind
in den letzten stunden keinerlei
personen zu schaden gekommen und auch
kein wohngebiet nicht ohne grund
befindet sich dieses munitionslager
mitten im grunewald damit so etwas
tatsächlich ausgeschlossen werden können
die flammen breiten sich ringförmig aus
die feuerwehr ist mit drohnen im einsatz
versucht sich jetzt ein bild aus der
luft zu verschaffen die tasten sich
jetzt also ran versuchen die weitere
lage zu besprechen löschhubschrauber
sind angefordert auch die neben der
feuerwehr die bundeswehr und das
passiert dann alles hier in den nächsten
stunden panzer sind schon vor ort und
wie gesagt der hubschrauber und
bundeswehr das kommt jetzt alles in den
nächsten minuten bis stunden ja das kann
uns den ganzen tag beschäftigen also
immer noch bei weitem nicht kontrolliert
die lage dort im berliner süden bei
diesem mega feier dort auf diesem
munitionslager gelände bei dem du hast
gesagt mehr als zwei fußballfelder groß
das gelände das der brennt seit den
frühen morgenstunden das ist ein
riesiges gelände aber vor allen dingen
ja das hauptprobleme im wasser lage hat
eine 50 tonnen weltkriegsmunition
und offenbar ja illegales feuerwerk in
großen großen mengen benjamin
richtig genau das ist die problematik
vor der die polizei steht vor der die
feuerwehr steht die hier seit vier uhr
morgens versucht diesem brand irgendwie
herr zu werden wir sehen jetzt hier
fahrzeuge vom thw wir sehen die berliner
feuerwehr
wir sehen im weiteren verlauf hinten
sind die autos die gepanzerten
löschfahrzeuge der polizei bereits durch
gefahren gepanzertes fahrzeug der
polizei hier auch noch im grünen steht
nach wie vor hier vor ort also sobald es
da grünes licht gibt sobald es da mehr
informationen über die drohnen bilder
gibt mit der die feuerwehr hier zur
stunde im einsatz ist rückt hier nach
und nach mehr gerät nach vorne jetzt
halt erst einmal die bundeswehr weil es
zur stunde tatsächlich viel zu
gefährlich ist sowohl für die
einsatzkräfte als auch für die leute die
hier vor ort sind und sich dann stück
für stück halt in dieses brandgebiet
bewegen müssen um dem vorzubeugen wurde
jetzt wie gesagt die löschhubschrauber
angefordert und auch die bundeswehr wenn
im intra mit vielen herzlichen dank dir
für deine informationen bewusst uns
natürlich im laufe der sendung immer auf
dem laufenden halten was dort passiert
bei diesem großbrand im grunewald danke
[Musik]